une photo en noir et blanc en souvenir
de ses jeunes années passées de sa
rencontre avec son mari et d'une vie
remplie de bonheur construite autour de
sa famille à presque 100 ans rita est
gay nous parle de ses proches
l'essence même de son bien-être la
finlande grèce pour mes enfants et ma
famille oui c'est ce qui vous permet à
huy mois pour moi les enfants utilisant
fois que ma famille ça c'est ma vie j'en
ris tassimo nuguet est né le 23 novembre
1916 mère de cinq filles et d'un garçon
elle est aussi grand mère de dix sept
petits enfants arrière grand mère avec
trente trois arrière petits enfants et
même arrière arrière-grand-mère deux
mots pour décrire autres mais mais
qu'est ce que vous direz joyeux et très
maligne elle est pleine de vie moi je
dirais qu'elle allait jouer et que
maliciels si m
rita exercé la profession de greffier au
tribunal de grande instance à saint
denis pendant près de 28 ans une femme
active autonome qui a tout juste 100
printemps souhaite garder son
indépendance par le mattel sa fenêtre
elle fait son glas fait part du temps à
la famine arrivent c'est déjà fait et
agréé yens en masse je lis je comptais
me coûtait donc j'ai toujours mon esprit
surtout le moral c'est ça c'est ce qui
permet de rester jeune ah oui et puis
bouger château de bougés de travailler
c'est toujours quelque chose dans la
maison fait n'importe quoi les recoins
de toto je fais tous mes jeux colonna
n'est pas là je fais mon lit je fais
tout depuis la mort de son mari rita vit
chez sa fille renée quinze années au
cours desquelles elle partage le
quotidien de ce couple et de leurs
enfants
le maintien à domicile des personnes
âgées est une politique sociale forte
défendue par le département de la
réunion
nous préférons que les gens restent chez
eux encadrés de leurs familles à nous
d'offrir à la famille les moyens en
versant l'allocation personnalisée à
l'autonomie
ou bien l'aide ménagère ou encore en
aidant ces familles à être accompagné
par différents autres dispositifs quand
ils sont quand ils doivent être
accompagnés au niveau du soin puisque
même quand on est malade ou sur unis
vous pouvez rester chez vous
vous avez un appelé avec des
prestataires qui viennent à donner si
cette jeune centenaire m coudre et se
passionne pour la lecture des livres et
des auteurs contemporains qui font
rougir et sourire rita quand l ampas
vous a dit que vous aviez lu la trilogie
de 50 nuance degrés c'est avec beaucoup
de légèreté que rita envisage l'avenir
l'essentiel pour elle sera d'être
entouré de ses proches
un amour familial qui est peut-être le
secret de cette jeunesse qui perdure
depuis presque sept années
vous feriez quoi être ces années 20
comme toujours je serai toujours mobile
comme toujours annoncer s'il faut
vraiment être devoir pas comprendre les
gens comme ça je pensais
merci qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter pour
les annexions reste encore un petit peu
y vendront temps avec ma bande de
familles d'enfants de six enfants sa
soeur changement n'est elle pas remis le
quoi la famille la famille beaucoup
moins pour moi c'est tout un raf a misé
tout